lebanon's three-time prime minister
appears to be planning a political
comeback Saad Hariri invited supporters
to his home to commemorate the 15th
anniversary of his father's
assassination former Prime Minister
Rafik Hariri it coincides with Lebanon's
deepening financial and political crisis
hadiri used the event to reposition
himself in the opposition camp blaming
his one-time political partners for
failing to implement reforms that he
says would have prevented Lebanon's
near economic collapse I am not going
anywhere
I am staying in my country in my home
and I promise you regardless of my
political position I will not leave any
stone unturned and I will tour the world
to defend Lebanon how duty formally
announced the end of his alliance with
the governing coalition led by Hezbollah
Hariri's calling for early elections
accord amande of anti-establishment
protesters who have been demanding
change for months he was eventually
forced to leave the country his return
to the Premiership in 2016 was the
result of a political deal with
Hezbollah Ally president
Michela that calculation cost him
support and backing of his traditional
allies the presence of high-ranking
members of one-time allies at the
ceremony could be a sign that had ADIZ
pro-western alliance known as the March
14 coalition could be reborn probably
probably what we need is performed a new
coalition a new form of local and
international coalition to safeguard
Lebanon and to support the Lebanese in
order to rebuild their country without
the hegemony of Hezbollah hardly enjoys
international standing but he's not as
influential as his father and in recent
years a shaky relationship with longtime
backer Saudi Arabia weakened him the
party that has the upper hand today when
it comes to the Bernese politics is
Hezbollah and his deed was Hezbollah has
collapsed
now his chances to come back are very
slim
at least in the near future how did his
resignation in October during nationwide
protests was seen as an attempt to gain
political capital he did try to return
as prime minister of a government he
would be able to control he failed
Hadid E is now promising a new path that
could change his political fortunes
senator al Jazeera Beirut